hey guys tie here with another gamespot
news update good news for you streaming
fans sony announced the next firmware
update for the playstation 4 will give
you the ability to finally turn off hdcp
Scott McCarthy Director of Product
Planning and software innovation at Sony
posted on the PlayStation Blog that they
are intending to make it easier for you
to share your gaming moments they'll add
a rich video editor with tools to
personalize your recorded video clips
which you can then export to a USB Drive
they are also adding a feature a
turn-off hdcp which is useful for people
trying to capture their gameplay via
HDMI this will make it easier for some
users to share longer clips McCarthy
also promises there's a lot more coming
with this update as well as separate ps4
system up they will also add the ability
for twitch broadcasts to finally be
archived as well as stream in 720p so
lots plan for playstation including the
new sony vr headset project morpheus
which was announced late last night can
be updated and all the playstation news
here at gamespot com